hola qué tal muy buenos días ángel
buenos días a todos a mis espaldas hay
una escuela aquí en la ciudad de buenos
aires es uno de los 17.500 poco más de
10.500 centros de votación que están
empezando a abrir en todo el país se
sumaron aproximadamente un 20 por ciento
esa es la primera disposición vinculada
con la pandemia para que haya menos
concentración de gente la otra es que se
le pide a los votantes que por favor
mantengan una distancia de dos metros
entre sí si están haciendo una fila
también hay un horario especial de dos
horas durante la mañana dedicado
especialmente a personas que tienen
alguna situación de riesgo y también
algunas cosas más pequeñas por ejemplo
que quien entra a votar cuando meten el
sobre la boleta o papeleta en vez de
cerrarla con saliva como se exija
habitualmente meta en la solapa del
sobre dentro del sobre como una forma de
cerrarlo y no toque la urna en el
momento de colocar su voto y también va
a haber kits higiénicos en las mesas de
votación para los votantes y para las
autoridades de mesa todas disposiciones
para tratar de prevenir contagios en
este contexto de pandemia